in the last video you saw how very deep
neural networks can have the problems of
banishing and exploding gradients it
turns out that a partial solution to
this doesn't solve an entirely but host
a lot is better or more careful choice
of the random initialization for your
neural network to understand this let's
start with the example of initializing
the weights for a single neuron and they
will go on to generalize this to a deep
network let's go through this with an
example with just a single neuron and
we'll talk about a deep manzanita so the
single neuron you might input for
features x1 3 X 4 and then you have some
a equals G of Z and then it outputs um Y
and later on for a definite you know
these inputs will be very some layer AOL
but for now let's just call this thanks
for now so Z is going to be equal to W 1
X 1 plus W 2 X 2 plus dot dot plus I
guess W n X n and and let's set B equals
0 so you know let's just ignore be for
now so in order to make V not blow up
and not become too small you notice that
the larger n is the smaller you want WI
to be right because E is a sum of WI X I
and so if you're adding up a lot of
these terms you want each of these terms
to be smaller one reasonable thing to do
would be to set the variance of WI to be
equal to 1 over N where n is the number
of input features as going into a neuron
so in practice what you can do is set
the weight matrix W for a certain layer
to the NP thoughts random thought Rand n
you know and then whatever the shape of
the matrix is you fold this out here um
and then times square root of 1 over
number of features set into each neuron
in their health is going to n of L minus
1 because that's the number of units
that are feeding in to each of the units
in layer now it turns out that if you
are using a rare Lu activation function
then rather than one over n it turns out
that said military institutions were a
little bit better so you often see that
in initialization especially using a
value activation function so if GL of
the years value of V o and tavella how
familiar you are with random variables
it turns out that something is Gaussian
random variable and then multiplying it
by square root of this that says the
variance to to be equal to this thing to
be 2 over n okay and the reason I went
from n to this n superscript L minus 1
was in this example with logistic
regression which is that any input
features but in more general case layer
L would have an L minus 1 inputs each of
the units and that layer so if the input
features of activations are roughly mean
0 and standard variants and the earns 1
then this will cause thee to also be
take on a similar scale and this doesn't
solve but it definitely helps reduce the
vanishing exploding gradients problem
because those trying to set each of the
weight matrix W you know so that is not
too much bigger than 1 and not too much
less than 1 so it doesn't explode or
vanish too quickly I'll just mention
some other variants the variation we
just described is assuming a rare Lu
activation function and it's by a paper
by her at all a few other variants if
you are using a ten-inch activation
function then there's a paper that shows
that instead of using the constant to
steadily use the constant 1 and so 1
over this instead of 2 so you multiply
by the square root of this so this
square root term would replace
this term and you use this if you're
using a damaged activation function this
is called savior initialization and
another version work cellobiose
evangelist colleagues we might see in
some papers but is to use this formula
which has some other server code
justification but I would say if you're
using a regular activation function
which is really the most common
activation function I would use this
formula if you're using tannish you
could try this version instead and some
motors will also use this but in
practice I think all of these formulas
just give you a starting point which is
your default value to use for the
variant of the initialization of your
weight matrices if you wish the variants
here this variance parameter could be
another thing that you could - or your
hyper parameters so you can have another
parameter that multiplies into this
formula and tune that multiplier as tall
your hyper parameter search sometimes
the tuning the hyper parameter has a
modern sized effect
it's not one of the first type of
parameters I would usually try to tune
but I've also seen some problems where
tuning this you know helps have some
usable amount but this is usually lower
down for me in terms of how important it
is relative to the other high
preferences you can tune so I hope that
gives you some intuition about the
problem of vanishing or exploding
gradients as well as how choosing a
reasonable scaling for how you
initialize the weight hopefully that
makes your weight your not explode too
quickly and not be k20 too quickly so
you can train a reasonably deep network
without the weights or the gradients
exploding or vanishing too much when you
train deep networks this is another
trick that will help you make your
neural networks train much more quickly